[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola
ese soy yo esa soy yo hace cinco meses
mientras que estaba terminando de
atender en el consultorio comienzo con
un fuerte dolor de pecho y atrás de eso
una muerte súbita muerte súbita yo soy
médico y sé muy bien lo que quiere decir
el corazón se para y aunque previamente
mi corazón era sano hice una muerte
súbita
mi nombre es karim a maynard y tengo 46
años
estoy casada tengo cuatro hijos soy
médica bombero y docente del nivel
terciario
yo trabajo en un centro médico con otro
equipo interdisciplinario entre ellos
tres médicos uno de los cuales es mi
marido
una enfermera camila y un grupo de gente
más
en ese momento yo empiezo a sentir el
dolor de pecho cuando camila viene a
preguntarme qué me pasaba llama a uno de
los médicos
yo le manifiesto que me dolía el pecho
me hacen un electro viene mi marido y el
otro médico también
me dan una medicación y me dejan
esperando a ver que cómo resolver el
cuadro yo continúo con el dolor y de
repente mi corazón para yo hago un paro
cardiorrespiratorio
mi marido que estaba ahí en un momento
le surge la posibilidad de quedar
soltero de vuelta y no hacer nada
pero bueno se acordó de que teníamos
cuatro chicos entonces comenzó con la
reanimación masajes cardíacos en el
tórax para poder reanimar me me coloca
en un tubo ese tubo es para ayudarme a
respirar una vía donde empiezan a pasar
medicación y yo nada continuaba en paro
llaman el servicio de emergencia del
servicio de emergencia viene de manera
urgente y me realizan dos descargas
eléctricas y nada
deciden trasladarme me suben a la
ambulancia suben conmigo y me acompañan
los tres médicos y en el trayecto de la
ambulancia llaman al hospital de bell
ville
yo soy de justiniano posse y nosotros el
hospital regional más cercanos en la
localidad de bell ville que queda 35
kilómetros y lo más difícil de la
entrada del hospital es el ingreso desde
que llegas a vivir porque el hospital se
encuentra como en la otra punta de la
ciudad implica pasar por el centro y
demorarse para unos 15-20 minutos para
llegar al hospital
mientras tanto llaman y dan aviso a la
gente del hospital lugar donde yo
trabajé por muchos años y mi marido y en
los otros dos médicos trabajan
actualmente
y avisan que iban conmigo y el estado en
el que yo iba que yo continuaba en paro
una de las médicas que estaba en el
hospital es una médica policial y avisa
a la policía la policía arma lo que se
llama un cordón sanitario de ese cordón
sanitario consiste en poner varios
policías o puestos policiales para poder
hacer que la ambulancia entre más rápido
y escoltando nos
un coche de con policía para que
nosotros pudiéramos llegar más rápido
cuando llegamos al hospital yo
continuaba en paro
y una manada de médicos estaba
esperándome porque yo trabajé mucho
tiempo ahí como les dije terapistas
médicos cardiólogos la gente de la
guardia
bueno en ese momento ya llevaba 40
minutos en paro
al ingresar ellos persisten con la
reanimación
una hora más
lo normal de esto es reanimar
dependiendo adecuada cuánto se reanimó
antes de llegar al hospital es más o
menos una hora y acá quiero destacar la
importancia de saber hacer reanimación
cardiopulmonar por parte de la gente
continúan con esta reanimación y de
repente un médico después que ya había
pasado una hora que no era mi marido
sugirió terminar con la reanimación ya
era momento de dejarme en paz hacía una
hora 40 que estaba en paro
y alguien de más allá dijo
cinco minutos más
cinco minutos más que para mí ahora
representan estar acá
en esos 5 minutos
mi corazón empieza a latir nuevamente
yo volví
y ahora acá empiezan a generarse un
montón de preguntas un montón de dudas
de cómo yo había quedado de cómo iba a
quedar después de esto cómo iba a
superar todas las complicaciones que
podía tener después de este episodio
durante tres semanas estuve internada
sin recordar absolutamente nada
yo estaba con una insuficiencia renal mi
organismo no podía eliminar líquidos por
lo tanto tuve que estar en diálisis
conectada al respirador no solamente
conectado al respirador sino también una
infección intrahospitalaria de la parte
respiratoria que es mucho más complicada
que una infección respiratoria en la
comunidad
y para terminar y broche de oro ocho
transfusiones de sangre
piensen ustedes
ocho transfusiones de la peor sangre
para conseguir 0 negativo para hacerla
bien completa peor yo no podía estar
tres semanas en la que me fueron a
visitar un montón de personas un montón
de personas hicieron oraciones mandaron
mensajes de buena onda
un montón de personas salvo creo que mi
suegra se demoró un poquito para ir
pero fue pobre fue
un montón de cosas que me perdí
en ese tiempo pasaron un montón de
acontecimientos uno de ellos el
cumpleaños de uno de mis hermanos el
cumpleaños de un sobrino el cumpleaños
de mi hija más chica
y el mundial me perdí el mundial cuatro
años lo espere y vengo a hacer esto
justo ahí
la última semana yo puedo decir que
recuerdo todo o empiezo a recordar ya
sabía quién venía a verme mi marido me
decía lo que me había pasado bueno mucho
no podía entender porque la verdad que
como les dije yo antes no tenía ninguna
no me pasaba nada me sentía bien
esta última semana todo mi organismo
empezó mágicamente a recuperarse
mis riñones comenzaron a funcionar y mis
pulmones no necesite más tubos de
sistemas de oxígeno no existe más vías
sacaron todas mis vías y yo quedé de
alta
cuando me llego me dan el alta llegó a
casa
y me encuentro con una situación que la
verdad nunca hubiera esperado sentir el
recibimiento obviamente de mi familia de
mis amigos gente conocida gente que
venía a saludarme gente que me mandaba
el mensaje en mi teléfono que era sonaba
todo el día
en ánimo de que yo esté bien y todo el
mundo se preguntaba realmente si yo
había quedado bien venían a visitarme y
esperaban ver que yo haya quedado con
alguna secuela que no hablara bien y yo
quedé así no sé si bien porque es
subjetivo el bien pero que de igual que
antes
y todo el mundo empezó a preguntarme en
la calle yo iba caminando por la calle y
la gente me paraba me abrazaba me daba
besos lloraba me manifestaba todo lo que
habían hecho todo lo que había pasado yo
salí a caminar y se agrupaba a la gente
para para decirme todo esto
yo me sentí lady di
sinceramente porque tanto amor tanto
afecto
empezaron a llamarme de radios de acá de
la zona preguntándome la gente que
también me preguntaba
y todo el mundo hizo una pregunta que
todos me la quisieron hacer pero pocos
se animaron civil a luz
no la vi el problema energético viene
difícil allá arriba también yo no vi la
luz
la otra pregunta que está si todos se
animaron a hacerme las sugerencias
fueron
que voy a cambiar ahora después de esto
que me pasó que voy a dejar de hacer o
qué cosas me quedaron pendientes que
ahora sí haría después de esto que me
pasó
insistieron tanto con ese límite digamos
de esto que me pasó ahora que voy a
empezar a hacer y que voy a dejar de
hacer que honestamente me empezó a sonar
y yo repasaba una y otra vez en mi
cabeza la lista que creo todos tenemos
de las cosas que queríamos hacer y de
las cosas que no queremos hacer más ir a
visitar algún familiar bueno ya voy a ir
o no quiero trabajar más me tiene
cansada y ya lo voy a dejar
y yo repasaba la lista y decía no [ __ ]
echar nada porque la verdad mi vida
hasta ahí era como yo quería que fuese
hacía lo que me gustaba y lo que no me
gustaba no lo hacía
entonces me hice la pregunta será que la
sociedad
vive a un ritmo donde se hace lo que lo
que la sociedad pide y demanda y no
podemos nosotros replantearnos esa lista
que vuelvo a decir creo todos tenemos
donde sabemos lo que tenemos que hacer y
no pero no lo hacemos
hay que esperar que pasen momentos
límites en la vida para cambiar y hacer
las cosas que si queremos o no
yo creo que vale la pena si ustedes
pueden cambiar y hacer las cosas que
quieren y no se dejen no esperen morir
para empezar a vivir vivan
[Aplausos]
[Música]